on être le césar de la meilleure
réalisation j'appelle deux immenses
réalisatrice qui ont tout de suite
accepté d'être là ce soir emmanuelle
bercot claire denis merci cette 35e
cérémonie des césars méritons tous les
lauréats et les remettons à rejoindre
sur sa nuque iguiniz arabe et sandy qui
vers l'un contre président pour la
traditionnelle
photo de fin de cérémonie alors donc
elle n'est plus revenue
florence foresti lundi nous avons révélé
dans notre émission média touche pas au
poste qu'elle avait touché un cachet de
130000 euros qui englobait ses auteurs
et sa prestation donc 130000 euros et
c'est vrai que tout au long de la soirée
florence foresti avait fait des
allusions à romane polanski regarder
bienvenus bienvenue à la à la dernière
ça la 45e
il ya douze moment où va donc on fait
avec
el papa
non alors il m'a fait pas comme lui
faites pas les innocents vous savez très
bien de qui je parle
qu'est qu'on fait à 4 mhz non mais je
veux dire on applaudit on n'applaudit
pas qu'on se mette d'accord parce que
vous êtes d'accord que je dirige hors de
question que j'assume ça tout seul de
tressol très sympathique je vous aime
beaucoup mais on dit la vérité autour de
la table est ce que vous comprenez des
jacques torrance forissier quitter la
salle et est ce que vous trouvez qu'elle
s'est loupé europe
eric naulleau sur ce convoi oui parce
que soit on accepte les règles du jeu
sont les accepte pas franck appietto
nous a expliqué que les résultats connus
il ya une chose qui était connu c'était
des nominés donc si vous acceptez pour
une somme assez rondelette quand même
d'animer cette soirée vous le fait
normalement
polanski et là vous aimez pas mais vous
prononcer son nom vous dit pas autre
chose ne vous dit pas popol fait un truc
un peu bizarre d'être déjà sur la
manière d'animer je trouve que c'est
raté après on quitte pas un quart
d'heure après en essayant de jouer sur
les deux tableaux du genre j'ai fait des
trucs mais faut quand même que je
manifeste que je suis contre polanski
elle a joué sur les deux tableaux à mon
avis elle a perdu sur les deux tableaux
du mit oui je pense que florence foresti
a probablement été la plus hypocrite de
la soirée je pense que quand elle a
accepté de venir elle savait les
conditions elle savait évidemment qu'il
y verra une très grande probabilité que
roman polanski puisse être nommé
réconfort récompensé je pense que c'est
trop facile de s'acheter une bonne
conscience
dix ou quinze minutes avant la fin du
spectacle balancer un petit post sur
instagram pour dire je suis écoeuré
après avoir empoché l'équivalent de dix
ans de smic 1 faut quand même le dire
ça peut paraître ridicule mais elle a le
droit de gagner son argent
peu importe que ces blagues et qu'on lui
a proposé à kampala
mais c'est trop facile à la fin bref
dans la vie faire des choix moi je suis
désolé je vous donne un exemple tout
simple
si demain venait h pas d'idée la
production de recruter par exemple
gilles importe quoi patrick petit hic
eric zemmour sur le plateau dans
l'équipe je sais que c'est pas l'heure
d'autres jours comme qui traîne je
quitte la d'emblée j'assumerai les
choses et je partirai je ne ferai pas je
sais que non mais c'est pas le cas mais
c'est pour dire qu'il faut faire des
choix dans la vie et c'est trop facile
de s'acheter la bonne conscience du
public à la fin en disant oh bah
finalement moi si je suis indignée
regarder je prends un peu d'argent je
vais pouvoir m'acheter une petite
voiture je vois pas bien le rapport bien
là tant il faut pas qu'on compare de
cons qu'on mélange de choses la réaction
d' adèle
el kihel je pense est justifié c'est une
victime bon si je pense comprendre -
accor à cadalen lorsque ces séances il
ya vraiment je suis d'accord et vous n'y
a rien à dire sur adèle haenel
elle a quitté la salle moi au contraire
je trouve qu'elle est un courage immense
de chenôve et devant tout le monde comme
ça et quitter la salle mois pour moi
adèle haenel
il n'y a pas de débat voilà en plus elle
était venue elle était nommée c'est
normal elle vient à l'aise dit mme bah
voilà non mais voilà eu pour elle je
suis voilà je me dis c'est 2k 10 ans et
de quatre compères c'est trop facile à
la fin de finalement il faut dire et je
me demande est ce que la chaîne va se
retourner contre elle est ce que les
scuds y avoir des poursuites la question
est là aussi
est-ce que alors réviser un peu dire que
dans son contenu à venir je vais vous
dire la vérité simple il y aura pas de
poursuites parce que la chaîne et les
dirigeants de canal + sont extrêmement
fair play voilà si j'avais été le
président de canal+
je pense que j'aurai vu florent ce
séjour est né voilà comment on fait
parce que c'est pas une question
d'argent mais peut-être lui demander de
faire un petit un petit mot de l'avenir
dira intime aux téléspectateurs de
canal+ mine de rien on va leur dire au
revoir
voilà après il va si elle était dans son
rôle le rat ne faisait ses petits tacles
à on peut trouver ça pas marrant mais ça
a raté mais c'est ce qu'on demandait
finalement dany mais elle fait un peu de
shopping trouve ça nul et mais elle
était dans son rôle mais à la fin foulée
sur les 10 derniers s'en va me changer
carrément énervé à la fin on voit que
ménard mais enfin de plateau et on ne me
parlait pas je suis trop choquer je
pense que la mise en scène est fait vous
ne faites pas ce que c'est un peu facile
de dire non ne me parlez pas moi je
rentre chez moi
foutez moi la paix je pense que c'est
sûr jouer peut-être que c'était calculé
je ne sais pas moi seul la vie sociale
elle le sait mais je trouve qu'elle est
grande de mauvaise foi et cela
probablement était la plus grande des
hypocrites sur ce plateau alors je veux
dire après après la cérémonie il faut
nice a pas été voilà très courtois entre
les patrons de nos canal+ et et florence
foresti et laura laura un peu gueuler
dessus voilà pour le monde à l'envers
comme elle le leur l honorable qualité
elle les plantes à la fin et c'est elle
qui s'énerve et parce qu'elle croit les
gens qui connaissaient le
e le palmarès mais il ne connaissait pas
du tout soit on perd et plus connaissent
pas le pas de la boxe à la nation mais
la veyron la danse vous n'en savez rien
dans la preuve a pas une personne qui
m'ait dans les enveloppes reyel est le
seul puisque fameux ballot de quoi non
elle a pu imaginer qu'il n'allait pas
être pris mais personne ne peut le
croire en plus sa police opposition est
totalement illisible
est-ce qu'elle a tout perdu dans cette
affaire parce qu'au final s'il était
resté jusqu'au bout peut-être qu'on se
raidit balle a été courageuse même en
étant contre cette remise de prix
elle est professionnelle arrêt jusqu'au
bout mais la dette reparti au milieu
elle a tout perdu parce que les gens se
disent à la fois les venus juste pour le
cacher mais ça c'est pas le propre
problème c'est ce qu'on travaille à les
payer en conséquence les machines entre
elles par un milieu en disant écoeurées
mais là ça va militer vous le savez bien
ça fait des semaines qu'on en parle on
en a déjà parlé ici
la probabilité pour qu'il soit primé
était tellement importante que si elle
avait voulu en réaction elle disait
qu'elle ne venait pas qu'elle ne
présentait pas terminée et les gens qui
n'étaient pas d'accord ne venait pas
dans la salle où ne regardez pas vous
êtes au salon de l'agriculture j'ai pas
regardé parce que j'étais pas d'accord
voilà alors ça sert à rien et dans une
seule les gens rien à moitié
après le dis c'est pas vraiment la même
est compliqué sera oui que si la prod
grand oui quand même
non mais je dis alors vous êtes d'accord
avec lens pour eux si vous comprenez
qu'elle est je comprends je vais je lui
accorde des circonstances atténuantes
parce que j'ai quelques la pression elle
était telle que c'est ça la pression
était telle dans la salle la pression du
public la pression de l'opinion la
pression attendue direct excellent
attentes même si tu es même si tu es une
comédienne etc
je trouve qu'il ya une telle pression et
puis justement ce déchirement de la
société tout ça repose sur elle elle dit
qu'elle doit porter elle n'a pas
découvert ce soir là ça fait des
semaines et des semaines on a par
exemple en scène avant même les
nominations on avait déjà eu le débat
et puisqu'il faut séparer l'homme de
l'artiste débarquant la pression quasi
leurs propres ailes assez de faire
quelque chose dans ce cas elle aurait dû
refuser
les quant à la cheville ils étaient deux
mois j'aurais jeunes chênes verts et
qu'elle reste j'aurais préféré qu'il
reste mais je peux comprendre qu'elle
s'en aille comprend déjà c'est la paix
sociale inss epica elle apprend jamais
bon et et qu'elle s'en est ma chérie tu
as raison je vais corporate ça peut se
comprendre
non cyril vous savez où vous et moi on
s'est déjà disputé je quitte le plein de
sueur et puis je reviens mais j'adore
j'ai pas eu 130 mille euros je les
attends mais jamais je vous avez plus de
chance de voir eric zemmour sur le
bateau que prendre soin tracteur vous
n'êtes pas quoi te doit les prendre
on habitait ici vous aimeriez qu'il
vient d'inviter oui pour la bagarre
c'est vrai car la bagarre
michel est sous l'eau dans la
performance de florence foresti
une des choses qui m'a frappé aussi
c'est la façon dont elle avec insistance
et un accent assez forts tels et soleure
epstein
mais sam stein strauss kahn oui mais pas
tariq ramadan oui alors ça il ya
beaucoup de relances je vous le dis ça
michel là je vous le dis il soulève un
truc qui a été énormément soulevées sur
les réseaux sociaux n'est pas se dire ce
soir mais c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
gens qui ont eu la même là même la même
réflexion que vous michel qui ont dit
pourquoi pas parler de tariq ramadan est
là mais je vous le dit un chanteur qu'on
adore tous voilà qui était voilà qui a
eu dès qu'il ya eu enquête a jamais été
condamnées rien du tout elle a mis
dedans
voilà vous savez de qui je parle j'ai
même pas envie de sédition parce que
j'ai pas envie de mettre là-dedans parce
que j'ai même plus envie d'en parler
parce que c'était ça c'était ça pour moi
c'était vraiment inadmissible
voilà mais c'est vrai qu'elle n'a pas
cité tariq ramadan elle a pas cités elle
a pas cités mine de rien alors moi je
dis allah m'a cité luc besson voilà
après luc besson il et voilà on sait pas
vraiment là mais bon en tout cas voilà
la cité des mecs qui était présumé
innocent mais elle a cité et stein à la
cité weinstein est la cité strauss kahn
strauss kahn exactement
mais c'est vrai qu'elle a pas citer
plein plein de gens et ça je vous le dis
sur les réseaux sociaux
ça a grincé ce qu'est ce que vous avez
vu ce qu'a dit la vérité ce petit truc
là qui a été relevée où florence foresti
n'a pas cité plein de monde
elle a ciblé c'est des gens et ça a
choqué certaines versions est ce que
vous l'avez vu ça je vous le dis sur les
réseaux sociaux y en a plein qui l'ont
vu alors nous on a on est on est
desservie son rôle à ce moment là
n'était pas là pour faire ça ces plantes
et mes souvenirs
c'te bonne heure michel jeury très bien
ça oui mais c'est ça justement si elle
fait ça reste jusqu'à la fin mais c'est
pas d'attiser la piste avait là vous
n'avez pas compris ce que voulait dire
pourquoi on fait des circonvolutions la
véracité que des gens de confession
juive
mais c'est ce que je vais me dire c'est
ça que je veux dénoncer les coupes
oui non mais non pas tout le monde le
pascaa ramène tout le monde savait que
il faut dire les choses on a compris on
et remet d'ailleurs ton intelligence
karim on avait compris ce navet m'ont
laissé le finir là c'est important oui
c'est pas et vous hésitez derrière les
choses non il n'y a que lui qui l'a
déclaré au but arrêter la raison car il
ya là peloton et l'a compris arrêter la
réalité si effectivement que la
communauté juive a le droit de se poser
des questions c'est vrai qu'elle du
moment est allé géant médiatique qui
sont accusé d'harcèlement de violences
faites aux femmes qui n'ont pas été
citées par florence foresti donc si
j'appartiens la communauté juive
effectivement je me posais la question
mais pourquoi je me suis donné pour que
des gens non sa grille ce que je veux
dire par là c'est qu'à un moment donné
vous a touché au plus profond de ce que
vous n'êtes quand un moment nous
appartenait à une communauté qui est
pointé du doigt
quant aux aussi me les musulmans dans ce
pays assurer que les écoliers fait
passer pour des terroristes
et quand vous êtes un adepte comités
régionaux vous êtes +16 moi je veux dire
qu'il ne l'est pas c'est la vérité qu'il
ya des musulmans ça n'aurait choqué
évidemment oui c'est ça le problème
c'est ça donc il ya beaucoup les réseaux
d'amis là où vous avez raisonne de
surcroît vous n'avez pas cité le
chanteur decaux populaire mais
effectivement flassian juillet un tri
bruel il est présumé innocent mais il
n'a rien fait pas vraiment de là rien
fait pour l'instant il a aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucun élément qui dit de ce qui
peut être accusé et sites et contenus
avec des jeunes qui auront connu rien à
voir la douane des comptes
et voilà on m'a vraiment à côté de quels
amis
moi je veux dire à la pire que j'ai la
parole à la question at elle bien fait
de partir je dis oui mais j'aimerais que
j'aurais aimé que mon poste en question
un talent bien fait d'y aller promis non
parce que mon nez il faut assumer
jusqu'au bout
bah non c'est conversion faite mais si
puisqu'elle y était depuis juillet alors
se trouvait par hasard mais non ça que
je veux vous expliquer en quoi est ce la
filière c'est qu'elle a c'est le final
se départit laisser la rivière là karim
je veux te condé je veux lui accorder le
bénéfice du doute sur le fait l imaginer
que nominé deux fois elle pouvait penser
et espérer d'eux qu'ils n'allaient pas
être récompensés et sacralisé voilà et
effectivement il y avait peu de chances
mais il y avait la possibilité
la réalité c'est que moi j'aurais mis je
le dis sur le cacher parce que le cash
est exorbitant et que les vins gagnent
de l'argent moi j'ai jamais eu déjà
menace même sur des sommes colossales et
n'y a pas de problème j'adhère de que
c'est comme ça c'est le milieu c'est
qu'elle a toujours aimé qu'elles disent
même avant de venir je vais vous dire
franchement voilà c'est une soirée
particulière puisqu'un fait que des
allusions mais mon cachet je vais là
très je vais le donner une association
qui qui qui lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes
voilà je suis une grande artiste qui a
dû conditions déterminées mais stéphanie
qu'elle n'est par des violences qui sous
en citant pas son nom en me parlant d'un
an quand elle sait que c'est que le
développement de polanski enfants a été
arrêté parce qu'il vivait dans le ghetto
de cracovie et que toutes les conditions
de vie l'hygiène existence question ont
joué dans son développement
moi je pense qu'elle n'a m'a servi la
cause de ceux qui veulent combattre a
fait de même c'est pas pleurer sur
polanski et je pense que ça vient elle
n'aurait pas pensé mais c'est vrai que
il ya aussi michel qui dit les choses
qui ont été relevées sur les réseaux
sociaux je suis désolé les deux trucs
qu'il a dit là ont été relevées sur les
roses en mesure maintenant on va pas
pleurer sur polanski ça c'est pas une
victime
c'est fanny ou assure florence foresti
au contraire moi c'est vraiment un grand
big up pour florence foresti
d'abord je trouve que l'hypocrisie ça
aurait vraiment constitué fin ça aurait
consisté pardon en venant en faisant le
job sans rien n'a rien d'accord quand
tous qualifiés au projet s'étaient même
c'était fin de carrière ce même avant
même florence foresti elle est connue
même avant cette histoire des césars
pour être investi dans le faire dans la
lutte contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles dont cali est allé moi je
trouve que justement elle a eu
énormément de courage elle y va sur ce
que des messieurs d'un shu mais jean
calas cité pas parce qu'il n'a pas assez
mangé on ne sait pas ça c'est juste que
atchoum c'était limite effectivement il
ya des sujets sur les gens qu'à la cité
qu'est ce que vous dites qu'il s'ouvrait
alors ces gens moi je vous avoue que
j'ai pa ti karaj à la pelote faut-il que
tous les jeux sur les réseaux cdma est
donné sinon après le fait qu'elle soit
partie moi je trouve ça très bien
moi je les trouvais drôle d'ailleurs la
fin mais aussi j'aime beaucoup faire
ensemble ce show mais voulait doji enfin
je trouvais que c'était important
justement elle en a parlé elle a changé
le cours de cette cérémonie qui
d'habitude était plate pas de vagues
faut surtout pas en parler
la volt obligé stéphanie mais oui allez
on se défoule j'en ai trouvé ça très
bien mais je pense pas que ce soit même
pour une fin de carrière pour elle
j'aurais été un truc libre a fait un
truc déjà raconté une coulisse à tous je
remercie
elle voulait pas le faire un moment elle
s'est posée la question trois semaines
avant elle a dit je vais je vais annuler
les îles ma présence au sénat est allé
les voir et je l'aurais je me dis voilà
j'ai eu des personnes de canal + je
l'aurais dit franchement si vous voulez
rendre un service à florence foresti je
pense je le dis parce que j'ai rien
contre elle et l'a coaché cette nina
mines une ennemie je connais pas trop
julie je pense qu'il faut qu'elle passe
son tour sur les césars cette année
parce que quoi qu'il arrive elle n'a que
des coups à prendre et ils m'ont dit de
mon répondu et m'ont dit écoute avec ce
qu'elle a prévu de faire je pense que ça
va être exceptionnel et au contraire il
veut se servir des césars pour faire
passer énormément de messages
voilà et à me servir de ça pour faire
passer énormément de messages donc on
m'a dit tu vas voir ce que tu vas voir
vraiment c'est
trois semaines avant oui oui même après
15 jours avant même après voit
l'allemagne et m'ont dit tu vas voir ce
que tu vas voir parce que là ça va
dénoncer je peux te dire que ça va
secouer ce qui l affaire florence
foresti aux césar moi quand on m'a dit
ça je vous dis franchement je me suis
dit bon je vais être sur le cul alors
oui et je vous dis franchement je leur
ai dit d'ailleurs lauriers mais qu'on
m'avait fait un teaser at il une pas
possible si c'est pour voir ça les mecs
ou foutez de ma gueule ou on n'a pas vu
la même révolte donc voilà donc je vous
dis la vérité voilà ce qui s'est passé
donc moi on m'avait vendu tellement un
truc énorme et tellement elle va faire
et elle va elle va dénoncer elle va tout
arrosé va est énorme
je me suis dit bon ça va être vraiment
on va on va s'en souvenir dans
l'histoire des césar je pensais pas
qu'elle avait juste dire à tous mes
trucs mon frère de 3 ans qui était assez
drôle hein voilà et qu'elle allait cité
voilà des mecs qui n'avaient rien à voir
là dedans je pense que c'est un petit
peu perdues moi j'ai trouvé très drôle
dd sur le début sur tout ce qui était
sketch tout ça après je pense qu'elle
était un peu agressive dans
l'agressivité c'est à dire qu'elle avait
tellement peur je pense qu'elle s'est
elle voulait peut-être trop en faire et
elle a mis à la mêlée des gens à cette
histoire qui n'avaient rien à voir et
qui se retrouve elle a vraiment qui se
retrouver cité et qui je veux dire je
veux dire que c'est inadmissible d'avoir
cité voilà je vous le donne mais la
réalité c'est que tu sais moi ce que je
comprends pas c'est qu'à partir du
moment où on veut pas cautionner que
polanski puisse être récompensés on
vient pas on film paraît bien sûr
celui-ci s'est compliqué comme ça mais
et de le dire
bah on m'a proposé d'animer les césar au
nom de mes convictions et de la bière
réalité de le voir même récompensé
honoré je ne vais pas car il est précis
rappelle ce que j'ai dit sur et césar
avant la cérémonie alors qu'on est dans
le groupe canal
qu'est ce que j'ai dit je regarderai
jamais des césars et surtout cette année
pour moi c'est de la merde en boite
voilà parce que je suis inadmissible
qu'il est 12 nominations et des actes
aux exactions et je regarderai pas alors
j'ai regardé pour l'élection tiens mais
c'est tout iad apple qui sont passionnés
avaient les midis de la toussaint
tu peux le dire en dehors de la tribune
des césar a bien sûr apple florence
foresti arrêté réponse a dépassé il est
exactement comme nous l avons déjà du
beurre et la crémière
j'aime et j'ai une question à vous poser
si relax que ce service répond parle
justement florence foresti serait bien
qu'on déplace pas le débat coupât danse
histoire c'est polanski c'est pas fort
et se tient sur lui qui aurait quand
même violé peuvent un carreau connu
d'avoir violé ce domise et drogué une
jeune fille ses progrès en ski et c'est
pas florence foresti il faut pas que
fasse le procès de l'ancien sûr je suis
d'accord ce qu'elle a fait ça l'honore
pas je pense que peut-être qu'elle
regrette après elle a eu le courage de
venir
j'aime bien le 230 millions si j'ai le
courage de faire beaucoup de choses en
revanche mais c'est vrai il aurait fait
pareil alors je l'aurais pas fait j'ai
un peu d'honneur par contre ce que l'on
peut poser comme question c'est est ce
que ceux qui ont participé au film au
film de romane policiers comme jean
dujardin désormais dans la profession
ils sont un peu finalement comme vus
comme des bêtes noires qui finalement
ont contribué à ce succès et qui serait
non pas complice de polanski est ce que
les acteurs spa est ce que les acteurs
veulent ils vont souffrir dans les rangs
du mur du jardin ça reste qu'à demi ça
va en fait attend dé vous parlez de jean
dujardin
moi j'ai trouvé déplorable sa sortie la
france a pu ouais t'as excuse moi mais
le jardin il faut quand même pas qu'il
oublie jamais dieu merci ce qu'on a le
droit de porter comme valeur quand on
s'appelle la france et quand arrive la
france a pu ça sent mauvais je me dis je
dégage
si je peux si je peux l'accepter sur ce
je venais je connais jean dujardin
je pense qu'il a vraiment chaude il a
été extrêmement blessée par toutes les
attaques qu'il a subies je pense que
voilà il a fait un petit voilà il va
mieux après il a compris voilà qu'il
avait un petit peu trop loin là dessus
mais on peut tous faire des petites
erreurs naturel ou dinard est il a
retrouvé
il a retiré un tom cary cantat ne savait
pas qu'il avait retiré tu as fait un
film dont on est fier il a il joue
extrêmement bien dedans voilà
dujardin dont le niveau là il a fait
d'elles voilà certains danseurs n'y a
pas trop de l'aca mais à un moment j'ai
été choqué c'est pour ça mais je
comprends karim et il s'en est pris
plein la gueule
il a regretté après il a retiré si le
retrait s'est passé et je te dis et jean
dujardin en plus c'est vraiment un mec
voilà au contraire il est fier de faire
tout ce qu'il fait en france je te jure
voilà c'est là c'est normal il s'en est
pris plein la gueule un moment tu vois
ccc il a été blessé